Hey team.
So,
things are lot more chiller out
here since the Point Four launch.
The users are happy,
our investors are happy.
And now that we've got
sharing implemented,
most of the features we want
in the app are basically done.
I've even had enough capital to
hire Paulter on as our attorney and
data scientist.
>> That's so great to hear.
It sounds like you're on track
to a very successful launch.
>> Wait, JP.
You're doing that thing.
>> What?
>> The thing you do when you're
worried about something but
you don't want to say it.
>> Well, you're both doing so well.
I don't want to rain on your parade.
I was just wondering if you looked
into some of the other features
Firebase offers?
>> Okay, like what?
>> Well, for example,
in version .5, if you have time,
you could look into providing
some basic offline access.
Firebase provides a few methods to
make it very simple to cache and
persist your data locally, even when
you're Internet connection is shoddy.
After that, you might want to take
a look at Firebase's offerings for
authorization and validation.
It jSon database like Firebase,
you can accept basically any
mishmash of key value pairs.
Firebase allows you to write
some data rules server side.
Then enforce the structure of your data.
In addition, you can write permission
rules that based off of your users
authentication tests, allow you to
control read write access to the data.
>> Okay, JP.
We'll think about it.
Right now working on a slide deck for
investors.
But, I guess I could have
the developer look at some of that.
But really JP its not like anyone
is actively trying to attack us.
[MUSIC]